non c'est vrai j écoute mon but en face
monsieur léonard devient de plus en plus
désagréable enfin vaincu vraiment trop
susceptible
si c'est parce que je suis susceptible
tu veut peut-être dire par là que je ne
vais que ce point rien elle vous êtes
exactement ce que veut dire le voici
fait il est bien d'abord c'est pas vrai
et puis ensuite je fais remarquer que je
n'ai pas été le seul à avoir été insulté
par les honneurs ne voyons où leonardo
n'a jamais insulté comment il m'a jamais
insulté bien figure toi julie qu'il m'a
claqué le couvert de saint malo n'est
alors
on s'est amusé mais je vais quand même
pas pleurer il me semble pourtant de
souvenirs que toi non plus une certaine
époque tu n'as pas toujours trouvé très
très très très aimable c'est vrai mais
c'est son caractère il est comme ça je
suis un très joli mais un caractère ça
se change pas et bien que veux tu que
nous fassions
on va aller les trouver je vais lui
parler et je lui ai expliqué qu'il doit
prendre sur lui il doit faire un gros
effort et au moins une fois par semaine
on peut puiser nabeul ont commencé un
bon après tout la raison ça lui fera pas
de mal de faire un petit effort allons-y
[Musique]
mon ami plairont printemps - ta plume
avons 21 mo
c'est drôle je me sens bizarre
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de voir des amis
de profiter du sang lundi dollar d'où
je le sent tout drôle
yoga
pour elle répondu par
bonjour je lui bonjour france excusez
moi j'étais en train de rêver à ce
niveau je suis ravi de vous voir
leonard tu es certain que tu te porte
bien aujourd'hui
très bien lorsque je vois un joli sur la
momie immédiatement d'humeur charmant
vous êtes trop gentil monsieur léonard
quand on vit dans une aussi belle main
au milieu de gens si simple
comment veux tu que l'on ne soit pas
aimable soi même mais excusez moi je
vous ai même pas demandé l'objet de
votre visite et bien je ne sais pas
enfin françois c'est toi qui voulais
parler à leonard non non non non non
c'est là oui oui non mais change non je
me suis un peu non nounou passion nous
sommes dit tiens nous en dire un petit
bonjour à léonard c'est vraiment gentil
de votre part d un artiste n'est pas
abuser juin je voudrais te demander une
faveur c'est ce gentiment demandé que je
ne peux pas trop fusée léonard tu es
très gentil je voudrais que tu me chante
ta chanson à bout oui mais je veux tu as
chanté la nar merci
[Musique]
à temps
à
[Musique]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
vous devrez faire
à trier
qui valide les garçons
casimir chante à sa chanson
françois
une volée facile
[Musique]
mais j'aimerais mieux pas son jeu
les geôles aurait mieux peu si j'étais
vraiment
[Musique]
à
ah ça
[Musique]
dans le kiosque les poupées
monde est en vie le collier
leur serine citron frais et groseilles
[Musique]
un papillon pas sur le banc
assis sur un banc géant
à regarder
puis tiré
on
mais je mourrai même pas si je veux
le jour est mieux que si j'étais à
nantes
[Musique]
non
bravo à mes yeux c'est vraiment très
joli avec bons coups des couleurs
à coup c'est beau
lennar je voudrais te présenter mes
excuses aux vie jeux j'étais très mal
jugé finalement retenu un excellent
caractère il pour te faire plaisir et
bien moi aussi je vais chanter ma
chanson poésie que tu vas chantier mais
je veux me cacher ma journée ou quoi
j'en ai ainsi nous tous et les gens qui
viennent en juillet alors que je ne
demande rien à personne allez sans
revoir
l'une
comment comprendre le caractère d'art
honneur